la gaude nord 27 mai première journée de
chaleur après un long hiver un coin de
pays toujours cannes à temps sauf quand
débarque une équipe de tournage
attention c'est du jamais vu
long métrage entier tourné dans une
réserve innu qui est niché en plein sept
îles j'aime entrer dans un lieu puis
prend des gens de la place
travailler avec ces gens là histoire
parce que oui si toute l'équipe
technique vient de montréal
tous les comédiens eux sont in ou
amateurs recrutés localement
l'histoire raconte la vie de deux filles
de l'enfance pour et et aux maisons à
toit à la jeune vie adulte ans à
construire une maison deux amis aux
destins différents
l'une veut poursuivre ses yeux de voir
le monde avec un jacuzzi en plus c'est
un personnage très vrai a comme en cent
premiers à être autant à l'aise avec
elle même avec son écriture est un peu
tout le long de l'histoire à commence à
s'affirmer affirmé son son besoin de
s'en aller puis d'explorer la autre
chose que sa réserve
l'autre à cet égard et son contraire
fatima côté on n'était pas capable
quitter sa réserve
c est 3 crée de bazar avec qui tu parles
d'un laser puis à la pause grand chose
au genre autres qui sa réserve
j'aime ça quand vous arrivez pas ce qu
on vous entend des rires en faisant
déjouer une histoire nous dit la
réalisatrice où l'on retrouvera des
thèmes universels amitié amour deuil
trahison c'est une histoire universelle
dans un décor je pense que je pense
qu'il faut arrêter de ghettoïser puis
cloisonner les histoires dans des
identités l'identité in où elle est très
forte ici pour la montrer mais ce que
nos personnages
oui c'est ce que
la plupart déjà ridant l'envi à 900
kilomètres de là des jeunes décrocheurs
votre tente de tout le québec reçoivent
des diplômes pour avoir réussi leur
retour aux études
[Applaudissements]
le travail de l'enseignant tinh où naomi
fontaine et souligné c'est elle qui a
écrit en 2011 le livre qu ici panne dont
elle ici un extrait se verra les
endroits où je me baignais lorsque je
sais pas je te dirais que même des
formes selon les caprices des images
c'est vraiment un honneur café à mon
livre elle est co scénariste avec la
réalisatrice myriam verreault de cuincy
panne
le film un projet lancé il y a 6 ans
j'avais des regards faut qu'on prenne
une chose ces questions sont pas simples
chez nous métis les choses peuvent elles
sont belles chez nous par contre c mais
il faut pas être ta ta ta ta ta première
vision à ta première ton premier regard
tout creuse un peu de taille un peu plus
loin qu est ce que tu es capable de voir
que le premier regard est un peu plus
négatifs souvent traîné y est c'est fait
retour sur la côte nord le beau temps va
durer une journée
les deux jeunes secte et si nous
versions enfin joue une scène extérieure
choisir de tourner un long métrage
uniquement avec des amateurs sans
expérience pose des défis alors appel à
l'aide
une comédienne de renom aussi formatrice
brigitte poupart est très important puis
main pour un acteur c'est de jouer une
situation plus que les répliques dans le
canton comprend la situation c'est plus
mon travail c'est de les amener là
un an suite d'écoutés quand l'autre
parle et de réagir comme on fait dans la
vie et ses essais et l'adq ont trouvé
les bases du jeu que sur un coup ici
panne on verra lorsqu'il sortira en
salles l'an prochain la réalisatrice dit
avoir voulu que le film ne soit ni
militant ni complaisant tout en restant
sensible à la réalité il nous ya déjà
qui pose la question qualys nous fascine
moi j'ai bu de l'eau c'est complètement
fascinant leur histoire de résistance le
fait qu'ils sont ici encore plus on va
faire des films sur les i nous plus on
va écrire des livres sur des inouk leçon
vaut faire des séries télé sur des noues
plus ça va ça va nous réconcilier j'ai
l'impression nous en premier les i nous
avec notre propre identité puis espérons
aussi avec les québécois avec notre
identité qui est commune aussi à quelque
part chose certaine ça a été une
expérience unique pour ces jeunes
comédiens amateurs
j'ai voulu changer là-bas plus arrogante
qui stationnaient m'a fait grandir
sharon elle déménage à québec pour
étudier en théâtre en ce moment je
pensais pas que j'étais fait pour faire
du cinéma ou du théâtre qui après cette
expérience là je peux dire que oui mais
je crois pas
tournage terminé les équipes sont
parties le calme est revenu mais tout
n'est plus comme avant
l'expérience cinématographique aïssi
changer des vies